uh what wonderful welcome I'm super
excited to be here it was fun talking to
Tom earlier and thinking back to I know
a number of you were undergrads and
thinking back to being in the class of a
guy named Martin Kilson who was my
favorite professor in college in cold
weather Cambridge Massachusetts and in
many ways was the guy who encouraged me
to go the entrepreneurial route but I
would love to share with you guys a
little bit of what has taken me on this
journey some of the things I've learned
good/bad and other and some of the
things I still wonder about because
hopefully I've got a lot more ahead of
me and and then at some point I'll stop
and would love to get questions from
those of you here I often say I didn't
start life off headed down an
entrepreneurial path I probably was more
likely to be a teacher I like to joke
that unrelated to more teachers anyone
you'll ever meet parents siblings aunts
uncles grandparents I come from a long
line of teachers and so that seemed much
more likely and in my family there was a
your earnest hopes that I would become a
lawyer I know you know in many families
lawyers and doctors sometimes engineers
are kind of particularly prized and I
think growing up particularly for me in
the 70s and 80s there is a sense that
lawyers often did really good things
often were involved in important causes
had been a meaningful part of the civil
rights movement Thurgood Marshall who
later became Supreme Court justice and
so for my grandmother who is from
Jackson Mississippi her her most fervent
hope was that her grandson the one who
used to break her chandeliers and cause
trouble and make her wonder if she had
one grandchild too many um she always
hoped that I would go on to become a
lawyer so um that was on the brain
leaving teaching behind and maybe going
on the law school was on my mind but my
sophomore year I took a course by a
wonderful guy named Martin Tilson and
any of you by any chance have heard of
Martin Tilson a chance
Martin Tolson was a wonderful professor
at Harvard I was
undergraduate now to look at him you
might confuse him with a homeless
gentleman you may not you may not know
any different he had used to have a
little kind of ragged hat that he would
wear his clothes were always rumpled and
he couldn't seem to quite find his way
but I tell you what professor Hillson
was one of the most thoughtful
interesting I opening people I ever met
and as I took his course which
interesting enough was not an
entrepreneurial course but was actually
a course on politics back in the back in
the fall of 1989 professor Kilson
challenged me and lots of other students
not just to think about law and politics
but to think about becoming
entrepreneurs and that doesn't seem very
remarkable today and that certainly
probably doesn't sound very remarkable
sitting here in Silicon Valley saying
that to you but sitting in Cambridge
Massachusetts in 1989 and having this
rumpled professor say to to a group of
students it included myself that as
opposed to thinking about the politics
that we were so focused on that maybe
part of the good change in the world
might come from entrepreneurs was was
really unusual entrepreneurialism wasn't
as broad basis sexy there were
incubators and accelerators and so it
was the first time that someone had put
that in my mind with that in my mind I
decided I wanted to learn more about it
and Harvard really didn't have
undergraduate courses and so I started
to wander around and I went to the
Economics Department and wanted to see
if some professors there would offer
some kind of independent study of course
they said now we won't do that over here
and so they sent me over to the business
school they said now we won't do that
interesting enough they sent me over to
the Kennedy School of Government if it
Knapp we won't do that they sent me back
over to the business school and as I was
walking dejected from the offices of the
of a nice guy who was the Dean Bill
Saltman who I don't know why he allowed
this undergrad in his office but I think
he didn't know any better I probably
slipped in the door quickly
he finally said well I have one other
idea there's this lecturer here who
normally teaches at Babson his name is
Jeff Kent
he's an entrepreneur and maybe you
should go talk to him and man oh man may
he rest in peace
uh Jeff Timmons was a entrepreneur we've
done really well with the beginning of
cellular phones and also the cable
industry who had decided to teach and
professor Tim and said why not why not
do an independent study mainly talk
courses at Harvard Business School and
he said why not allow this undergraduate
independent study was made to sit in all
my classes visit lots of interesting
businesses and so I be aníbal journey
with Professor Timmons and he would have
me go and meet with different small
business people a t-shirt maker guy who
owned a couple of pizza shops someone
who owned a radio station and asked him
about the good the bad the ugly but I
want to came down to premiership and and
that really was the first thing that
again kind of took professor Hillson
kind of a seed of an idea and took it
further and I think part of what I heard
in the variety of people that I ended up
talking to was that it wasn't easy and
that was probably the most uh the most
obvious thing um go forward a little bit
i graduating from college I'm thinking
man I would love to try something
entrepreneurial my dad was I told he's a
teacher my mom was a teacher he was not
that excited about his boy with a
Harvard to create going to do some kind
of startup that wasn't exactly on his
list of plans and I had this crazy idea
that dese need anyone here I bring
before wings before they were big your
friend said they were going to be big
and my dad was like nads a bad idea
don't do that no one's ever going to eat
them why would anyone want them
delivered like did I'm telling you these
things are great you don't always want
pizzas you know these other things are
good too and lo and behold for better
fors
he talked me out of it it was a good
lesson though and it's a lesson probably
a lot of entrepreneurs learn which is
good a lot of times you're wrong but
sometimes you're right and sometimes
when you're right now
everyone's going to be able to see it
right away and while you've got to be
thoughtful enough to listen you may not
always follow even the advice of those
closest to you namely your dad whose
name you borrowed because I'm Carlos jr.
so so now we are five or six years into
it and I still haven't really stepped
out and done the entrepreneurial thing I
do go to graduate school eared Stanford
and loved it
I love the Sun love the people love the
openness this was kind of early 90s and
so while there still were memories and
kind of Legend and lore of uh of Hewlett
Packard at the time and Steve Jobs and a
handful of others wasn't it at least to
my mind as robust an entrepreneurial
environment as there is today and it
wasn't immediately obvious that those
opportunities were out there not just
for kind of entrepreneurial
opportunities but even I remember when
one of my buddies who graduated mid 90s
got a job in venture capital right out
of business school that was considered
quite unusual so the environment my mind
wasn't as rich and it's interesting but
I still I had thoughts in my mind that I
wanted to do something but I took a
safer route and decided to go work at
McKinsey and company any McKinsey or X
McKinsey folks here okay this one you
know couple a couple good folks and so
that was a wonderful opportunity it was
unusual because I was coming from the
law school so I wasn't part of the
Business School tribe but I was one of
the folks who came from science or
medicine or one of the other places in
my case it was law and as I went into it
a good friend stopped me and she said
you have to promise me that you're not
going to stay longer than two years she
said I know you want to do something
entrepreneurial and I know if you get in
there and you don't go in with the
mindset but this is limited you'll end
up looking up and it'll be ten years
twenty years later and so that was
another tick along so I go into McKenzie
and actually she helped me a lot in
saying that because I went into McKinsey
not just wanting to do a good job in
general because I'm a mother son and
that's what she wants you to do but but
also because I started to think about it
more practice
I started to think the better I was for
my clients maybe one day the better I
would be in advising myself and my
partner's and my investors on how to
make whatever I started grow so again
slowly these things are building up in
my head and spending time at McKinsey
wonderful opportunities some here some
overseas finally in the in the later 90s
I decide to go for it and along with a
good friends in college and one of my
sisters I decide to start an education
company called Achieva
and actually I take that back wasn't
called the Chiva originally it was
called Sierra that's called the Sierra
College Prep services and why Sierra
Sierra just sounded peaceful sounded
like someone who could bring you joy
we ended up changing the name because it
didn't make sense anyone but um but at
least at the time we started and as I
the way I ended up doing I spent a bunch
of time thinking about it right in a
business plan putting all that together
and then with that I went to go talk to
a guy who would kind of become one of my
mentors and he's a super wonderful guy a
Mark Jones any of you heard of Eris a
wonderful internet-of-things company if
you don't know air is not always a
wonderful company that's run by one of
the most wonderful people in the world
Mark Jones I get teased all the time for
saying everyone's nice but mark is
certifiably the nicest guy who's never
been created so but mark I want to go
see mark to tell him a little bit about
this idea that I had former college prep
company and Mark listened dutifully
asked a couple of tough penetrating
questions and then Mark went away just
like where did you go because we kind of
disappeared a little bit abruptly and
when he came back he came back with a
check he came back with a check for
$15,000 and I realized that to some of
you that won't sound like very much but
for this kid from Miami back in 1996
that was a huge vote of confidence and
Mark said you know he said Mark came
from kind of a similar family of
teachers and he said
I know how hard it is for someone like
you to think about walking away from the
McKenzie paycheck to start something and
if I can be a little bit of an
encouraging along the way if I can be
one of the people who pushes you further
down the road than I want to do it
so mark handed over that checked he
didn't say this was a loan he didn't say
I want X Y and D for it he said go forth
and do the best he can and so at that
moment I was committed I was I would
been to it the next call went to my
favorite uncle I have a wonderful uncle
who looks just like my dad and had the
ability to be more fun because he didn't
have to put up with my problematic side
and I called my uncle Dunbar's we've
never gone to college my uncle number
hour passed up college so that is other
two brothers which included my dad could
go to college and he worked at the
equivalent of worked at a big oil
company for 40 years as a technician and
when I called uncle Dunbar and told him
what I was thinking about Dylan he and
at the time I just I was not smart
enough to really understand and
appreciate what he did but uncle Dunbar
had about a hundred thousand dollars in
his 401k and he wired the whole thing to
me and to my sister and and that was his
whole savings that was that was
everything and and and and he wired it
to me a couple days later and so with
that my good friend and my sister and I
thought were onto something we're about
to win this is going to be good and and
we began what ended up becoming a five
five and a half year journey which was
neither is as easy as maybe I would have
thought and not as straightforward lots
of interesting surprises but we ended up
building a nice company achieve a
college prep services that help high
school students prepare for college so
not just yes ad prep but what college
should I go to how am I going to pay for
it what are these things called essays
that they want you
ask for a letter of recommendation
offering all that kind of advice and a
comprehensive way via software books and
workshops not just individual families
ultimately the big school districts like
Miami and Chicago Detroit and others we
ended up selling it years later to the
Washington Post which owns Kaplan and
much of other education companies as
well but it became a big part of my
learning a big part of my growth a big
part of kind of shaping shaping who I
was and I'm going to come back to that
in just a minute and hopefully tie a
number of these things together while at
the chief I was on TV a couple of times
and talking about achieving what we were
doing and so yeah random call from a guy
named Elliott one day who said in effect
he left a voicemail he said I saw you on
TV
wondered if you'd ever think about doing
more of that I'm in charge of what they
call development would you consider
talking to us well I didn't believe
Elliott was really called a couple of
times and that's because I have a very
good friend named Rachel and what Rachel
loves to do in this life and Rachel if
you're watching I'm talking about you
uh-huh Rachel loved to play pranks on me
back in the day Rachel lived in LA and
she would have people call me and say
just Carlos yeah were you just at this
party in Hollywood yet look we've got
this new movie coming out we need
someone to star opposite Halle Berry we
think you'd be great do you want to have
breakfast tomorrow and of course I was
dumb enough to say oh sure of course
you're calling me of course not ready to
do this and Rachel would call back a few
minutes later say hey we'll have
breakfast only I can't have breakfast I
got some poured she's like why because
you're talking to someone who sounded
like this and so and so I just assumed
this guy Elliott was just another Rachel
prank I ended up talking to Rachel and
it turns out that this time it's not her
and I got so upset with her I said see
you caused so many problems over the
years I'm now looking give force and
about luckily the guy called back ended
up having an interesting conversation
and I ended up a couple months maybe a
year later beginning what became an
interesting
career in television first starting out
as a guest host I don't know if you guys
know but it turns out that there are
groups of people who work for TV
networks that are scouting for talent
all the time and often look for people
who guest appearances and think could
you do more could you do more as a talk
show host could you do more as a regular
host what have you and so I ended up
spending much of the next several years
in television at CNN at MSNBC doing
various kinds of shows often kind of
interview shows and really really
enjoyed it but a few years ago sadly
while I was in the midst of that and
living in New York my mom got really
sick and I she was living here and and
so after a little bit of back and forth
I I left that and came to move out here
to take care of her and and while I had
never had anyone in my life who would I
was really close to who were done who'd
gotten that sick she got she had lead
stage cancer and and and so it probably
for the first time I didn't I don't know
if any of you were like this but I
definitely for whatever reason assumed I
was going to live a super long time my
mom my mom's mom had lived to 102 both
of her grandmother's had basically lived
to 100 and we used to always joke that
she was going to live to 125 I was going
to get to a buck 50 and we all were
going to go quite the distance I was as
we she was obviously surprised when it
turned out that it turned out she was
sick and and so it really made me and I
realized still sound a little hokey but
it definitely made me rethink life a
little bit definitely made me appreciate
it may not go as long as I expect that
it could end sooner than I know and so
really kind of pushed me to ask what
would I love to do what would what would
bring great joy what might I be good at
and so began doing a fair amount of
soul-searching and she was part of it I
was often driving her to doctors
appointments
starting to think and she would pepper
me she ever the teacher she was a
teacher as I said for kind of 40-plus
years teaching everything from
kindergarten to college and she would
pepper me with questions about what do
you really want to do what do you love
and I realized that that there still for
me was a hunger and a desire on to do
another startup that as much as I had
learned and enjoyed Achieva
and as hard as I worked and in many
hours as I put in and as much weight as
I gained working seven days a week for
five and a half six years straight that
I wanted in again and I want it in with
something that I really cared a lot
about which for me I had always I think
in no small part because of my dad I'd
loved the news and I'd loved figuring
out what was going on and it was less
just an intellectual exercise of no one
kind of what's happening when and more
my dad always introduced you to the news
whether you were listening to it
watching it reading it as a way to kind
of expand your sense of what you could
do and so when he would read something
in the paper or hear something on the
news he would translate that
conversation you were having with your
buddy Billy or that school project you
had or that thing you told them you
wanted to do and so I started to think
about where the news was at that point
which was a couple years ago and I found
that I loved it as much I found that it
would become a little hmm little
predictable in a lot of cases meaning
that whatever the handful of big stories
were around the world would be the same
story you'd see in most publications and
so even though I had more choices
digitally in terms of where I get my
news from that I did as a kid I found
that often they were repeating or
emphasizing the same four or five
stories and so I started to think what
would different look like what would
magical look like and I started on a
journey of talking to folks at HuffPo
and box and BuzzFeed in the New York
Times and NPR and other places but then
in LaGuardia Airport I bumped into a
wonderful guy named David Neelam and any
of you ever hear of David Neil Elman
him did he even Illman founder a JetBlue
and also I guess that's all
now any of you guys ever fly JetBlue
back in the day I love gentle it first
came out I and I remember meeting the
debut in the airport and and saying to
him listen well how did you make an
airline that I have an emotional
reaction to I actually loved I kind of
look forward to then I go out of my way
to fly you guys I'll change the time I'm
going to fly I'll change the location
from which I'm flying how did you do
that he said cause I spent a lot of time
studying the business in fact he'd
started an airline before JetBlue that
he'd sold the Southwest airline he said
Benny and I kind of trusted my gut and
what I loved a little bit and so here
was a guy who was kind of slightly tall
not super tall tired of having his knees
banged and made sure that everyone had a
little more room and I can't remember
how many kids he had but he said Carlos
you know what happened ten he said
Carlos you know what happens when you
have that many kids you know what you
want more than anything else I said what
he said TV time and said I don't know if
you guys remember but JetBlue was the
first to put TVs on the back of
everyone's thing so I say that only to
say that part of what David Newman did
for me would save it as I started to
think about trying to reimagine than it
is as I started to say that as much as I
loved the New York Times or NPR USA
Today or any of the other places I'd
gone a lot too if I really was going to
think about trying to creatively
reimagine it it wouldn't just be doing
the McKinsey
competitor research with you that party
would be kind of following my heart and
asking myself and maybe others I trusted
what would you love what would make you
break habits and start to try something
new and so as much research as we did my
partner Samir and I and wonderful guy
named Sameer Rao decide okay let's stop
and actually ask ourselves that question
what would it take for us to follow
along with a new and different kind of
news site what would it take for someone
to do what and we were inspired a little
bit off to tell you by Apple and HBO and
Tesla what would it take for us to
reimagine a space with all these things
plenty crowded and I say that meaning
that for those of you who don't remember
the computer space was pretty crowded
when Steve Jobs returned to Apple in the
late 90s it wasn't immediately obvious
that anyone needed a new
different computer company and yet still
with that little colorful iMac and a lot
more they managed to reimagine what was
possible there and for those of you who
like me give credit to HBO for kind of
kicking off this golden age of
television
many of you remember that when HBO
finally started getting hot with Sex in
the City and a bunch of others it was
not at a time where there were three or
four TV channels already by then I had
dozens of choices but HBO is still kind
of colorfully reimagine what TV could be
and so in our mind we thought as crowded
as this space may be there may be a
chance to kind of think about this whole
thing differently four things stood out
for us that we thought we had to do in
order to become for our target audience
which we often call the change
generation not the only place that they
go for their news information but we
hope their first and favorite first we
thought we have to do a good job of
catching you up on the big stories of
the day right we got to do it quick we
got to do it fast
almost as though you were the President
and hence we created something called
the presidential Daily Brief which some
of you may see when when you look right
here and hope some of you are readers of
the presidential Daily Brief but once we
caught you up we thought the second
thing we could do it may be the more
important thing we could do is vault you
ahead could we introduce you to the new
in the next weather that meant new
people new places new trends new ideas
not a minute or an hour head like might
happen with Twitter but could we
introduce you to people in places and
things three months six months 12 months
before you normally might see it on CNN
or you might read about it in The Times
and so not LeBron James or Sheryl
Sandberg but maybe the next LeBron or
the next year old Sandberg and we were
inspired in part by wired any of you
remember wired back in the day when
wired first got started a wired fans
early on when wired first got started
you would read stuff in wirings to sit
in Borders bookstore for anyone who's
remembers Borders bookstore on
University Avenue I used to sit in
Borders bookstore and you would read
stuff and why is that you would only end
up seeing in mainstream publications a
year or two later there any music fans
here I would say that's what the source
and pitchfork used to be like a little
bit where they were clearly ahead of the
curve so that was the second big piece
for us but we not only catch people up
at welcome ahead the third thing is we
thought that design and style and flavor
was
longer just a nice-to-have but it was a
must-have for our target audience that
part of what Apple had done would say
that you know what for a new generation
of people like whether you've got
headsets or thermostats whether you've
got a TV show or a place to eat they
want some style and flavor and so how we
design how we wrote how we filmed how we
edited what are we sweeten with music we
thought all of that was as critical to
us as it was to HBO to Tesla to others
and so we thought that was a third piece
and then last but not least we thought
not only did we have to catch you up and
bolt you ahead and do it with style and
flavor but if we really were going to
win over our audience they would never
want to think that they missed out on
something because Ozzy was really
narrowly focused that Ozzy was only
telling them about the new in the next
from the US they'd want to believe that
objects tell them about the new in the
next period and so oddly from the very
beginning was really global and you
spend time on Ozzy you will end up
seeing stories from Morocco and Burkina
Faso and Bolivia as well as from Boston
and and San Francisco and so those are
kind of a four big pieces that we set
out with three and a half years ago and
hoping that we would build for our
target audience which again we call the
change iteration not the only place they
would go for their news but we hope we
would build the first and favorites now
take a moment on the change generation
that I referred to often when people
hear me say that they think I'm
referring to Millennials and as my mom
would always remind me it was more she
said the change generation is a mindset
it's more of a psychographic than a
demographic it's people who aren't just
okay with things being different but
people who actually often think of
different with as a positive connotation
different food different clothing
different candidates different different
person to spend time with and so for
those folks we wanted to become there
first in favor which might name largely
Millennials and Gen Xers but not only
and so that was the journey we began on
about three and a half years ago and
give you a little bit of a demo ah the
presidential Daily Brief as I said would
produce it every day and it's meant to
say here the kind of top ten stories but
here on the right and on the Left you'll
see usually about a dozen stories each
day that we hope to introduce you to the
new in the next and whether that's an
opinion piece or whether that's a rising
star whether that's a piece from
the world of politics or even what we
call good huh we hope that we're
the place that you get a chance to
discover the new Daily Show host a year
before he's chosen or the first pick in
the NFL Draft or maybe the first time
you read about a new book or a new TV
show we'll be uh naughty that's part of
what we hope to bring to you Ozzy's
grown today about 25 million people
every month will read us or watch us or
listen to us slightly more women than
men about two thirds here in the u.s.
about a third outside of the US get
about 75 people on the team that 25 here
in the Bay Area 25 elsewhere in the US
and 25 around the world and as we sit
here at this moment I probably would
tell you that there are four or five
things if I were talking to my younger
self that I would say Carlos probably
would surprise you about this journey
the first thing I would say is that it's
my first company when I started I later
on said that maybe one of the most
important hires and the hires that you
don't appreciate the value of as much is
your head of Finance sometimes called
your CFO that until you have a really
good one
you never realize how much money you can
blow through and how unfortunate that
can end up being but I will tell you
that one of the interesting challenges
and opportunities that I've learned
about this time is in many ways the
importance of HR the importance of the
people who are in charge of people and
culture is critical and I'd say it's
even more difficult today than it was
when I started my first company when I
started my first company very few people
were entrepreneurs you didn't have TV
shows like Silicon Valley you didn't
have movies like the social network you
didn't have 500 startups and so I think
there at least was a little more there
at least was a little more mystery to
what a start-up was about today I think
so many of us see kind of a handful of
companies that win and do well and we
assume a lot of times that it's easier
maybe than I think it is and I and as a
result we see the good food and the cool
drinks and the game can we assume that
that's at the heart of it and I would
say that it is
and it has been humbling to realize that
one of the most important things that I
have to do as a co-founder as a CEO is
really help people appreciate how much
hard work is going to go into it and
that no matter how much hard work we put
into it still relatively few of us are
going to end up being meaningfully
successful at it that doesn't mean that
we won't try hard doesn't mean won't
have a good idea but I'd like to say
they call it 500 startups for a reason
because there's one Airbnb right and the
other 499 or 400 who knows how many are
people who are going to put a ton of
time in and probably aren't going to end
up exactly where they'd like to be and
so that actually was the first
interesting thing which is it it became
really important for us to get some help
in helping our team think about what
it's like to be part of a start-up what
kind of commitment they're making which
may be different than what they see on
TV or read about or hear about elsewhere
so that was one of the surprises I would
point out and I would say the second
thing I probably would say to my younger
self is a lot of times when you hear
startup we talk about the creativity
that's involved we talked about the
energy sometimes they talk about the
all-nighters we talk about the push we
talk about can you find terrific
investors I would say that one of the
skills that I think is absolutely
critical and that at least I didn't hear
anyone talking about was the importance
of been incredibly organized I you know
it's funny I think a lot of us think
about startup and we think chaos and I
think the reality is it's hard to get
stuff done and it's chaos and yet those
places I think that are better organized
that actually follow through they get
things done that if some simple as this
sound have agendas and have follow-up
items and actually tick those things off
I think often disproportionately those
are the ones that end up letting I
remember years ago talking to a guide
until Campbell I don't know the bill
ever come and speaker as well
bill who was advisor to a lot of
terrific CEOs from Mark Zuckerberg and
Larry Page to Jeff Bezos used to say
that the biggest transformation he had
seen in the last 25 years of advising
CEOs was the number of visionaries who
would become superior up
laterz that is he said they came to
realize that no matter how big and cool
their idea was if they couldn't actually
implement it if they were really
organizing on top of it and the kind of
person who could bring it to life that
it wouldn't come to life that they
couldn't simply hope that someone else
was going to do it and so I would say
that would been the second thing that I
would have emphasized and it's not a
skill that you hear talked about as much
but I would say that probably was a
second surprise I would say a third
thing that I probably would have
surprised myself with a little bit is if
the beauty of a great partner um who
here has had a really good partner
before in sports and love and life and
business who's had a great partner
before yeah um I I I should have known
it um
I should have known it but I right and I
had good partners at my first coming but
I learned it all over again it's what's
been interesting about this time around
it Ozzy is in effect I really feel like
I probably have two partners one partner
is Samir Rao who we started the company
together and Samir's from Detroit
Michigan area originally younger guy we
bumped into each other again we known
each other a little bit but we bumped
into each other in the parking lot of a
Chipotle and there began something
really good um and our other partner has
been a wonderful woman named Louise
Rodgers who until recently led a kind of
billion-dollar digital company in the UK
that just got sold a little bit ago but
started life off as a waitress and so
we've been a we've been good partners
even though and I'd say maybe because we
have very different approaches I'd say
if you gave Samir and me kind of ten
scenarios and said you guys answer what
you would do in these cases
I bet to Samir and I are answers even
after four plus years together would
only overlap six times and with Louise I
think we probably would only overlap
three times and that's even after we've
worked together a lot so very different
approaches and yet we have been I think
we've been an incredibly effect
of partnership I think there's been an
openness to debate I think we've been
very willing to allow for lack of a
better term silver bullets so if it's
clear that this matters to Louise and we
could argue about it forever but the
reality is that that's kind of where she
is and this one really matters to her
we're going to go in that direction same
with Samir and hopefully the same with
me but I will tell you that finding
finding that partner which I don't know
that I can really say I can't think of
as a science but I don't know that I
could give you great advices so where to
look for that because it really was
wonderful happenstance in the case of
Samir and I coming back together again
in that parking lot of Chipotle but but
I will tell you that a great partner is
a blessing and my my wonderful fiance
says that as I was starting to think
about what became Ossie I would complain
a lot until the day that I bumped into
Samir again and that the minute I bumped
into Samir that the complaining stopped
and the progress started and so I
probably at someone who was driven and
and and eager and confident I probably
underestimated or his former President
George Bush would have said miss
underestimated the importance of a the
importance of a really good partner and
so that probably was another one of the
things that surprised me um last couple
of things I'll share with you that would
have surprised me and then I'll stop on
uh you know I don't think of myself as
someone and and maybe it's um I'd like
to think that I'm open and I'm
thoughtful and that there's not a ton of
hubris and yet after our first year we
had as good a first year as someone
could have when we first got started we
we felt like we launched with a good
product we brought in wonderful
investors we opened with partnerships
with NPR in the USA Today where we got
to do very interesting things with them
we got a call from Bill Gates's chief of
staff a couple months in saying our boss
la really likes what you guys are doing
and can we send
people down we had all sorts of good
things that started to happen right away
and our audience started to jump really
quickly in terms of size and before the
year was over we had on top of the angel
round we had raised we managed to raise
a twenty five million dollar round not
which was fairly unusual at the time in
fairly significant so we had a great
year on and then we punctuated it uh-huh
by absolutely I don't know if you can
absolutely just up as great as
great a freshman year as we had and
maybe some of you guys can relate to
that we had a horrible second that
sophomore year I mean it felt like
everything that could go wrong did go
wrong we care about design so much that
we decided to redesign our site and our
look and we did it in such a bad way
that it literally screwed up our
back-end analytics and really messed up
our traffic growth in really bad ways
not to mention kind of pissing off our
users we went into the market and tried
to hire folks who we thought would be
would really elevate us to the next
level and on paper these are really
accomplished people and I know a lot of
other circumstances they had done well
and I'm sure still will do well but this
turned out not to be right hires for us
so we made some hires that set us back
and on and on again and so I think
another thing I would say to my younger
self is the minute that year seems too
good to be true be humble enough to you
appreciate that some of it was probably
just good old-fashioned luck and uh and
DoubleDown afresh um the last thing I
will tell you about my entrepreneurial
experience and then I'll pause and and
and would love to take some questions as
well is I really like a blank sheet of
paper I know not everyone else does and
I know sometimes it can be intimidating
to think where do you start and is this
right or wrong but I i if you like blank
sheets of paper if you like
to create something afresh if that
doesn't scare you but that actually kind
of pulls you towards it and you love the
idea of kind of building something new
that wasn't there before then I will
tell you that being an entrepreneur is
one of the most wonderful things
possible there is nothing like going
from a blank sheet of paper to a big win
and whether that the site getting
launched whether that thinking about
ways to get people to fall in love and
millions of people doing that last year
we launched our very first television
show meaning we took some of our digital
series and turned it into a television
show and sold that whether that's been
creating an offline experience mainly a
big festival where people who were
reading and watching and listening nas
we could come in and enjoy um all of
that has been terrific and I think as
much as I could have guessed that I
would enjoy it I think for some of us
there's a particular joy if that turns
out to be you I think entrepreneurship
and entrepreneurial opportunities could
be terrific so much more that I could
say but I know I'm supposed to stop and
take questions so that's a little bit
about my journey about some of the
things I've learned but I would love to
to take questions and go from there
[Applause]
so first of all Carlos you know very
much for your talk and he's very
interested to see your like how evolved
you know from Stanford and napintas and
working at the knee and then making this
education startup and then now you are
in schools what is that in your personal
life has been like this
read read like be kept on creating yeah
so so given that I've tried very
different things from startups to larger
places like McKenzie and Goldman to
television - now Ozzie what would be
kind of a thread that brings it all that
brings it all together um I guess this
may sound a little a little weird but
probably just a willingness and a
confidence to try different things I
think a lot of times any of you guys
have a read up Paulo Coelho the author
who wrote the alchemist a lot of other
things you've got this great bit at the
beginning the alchemist where he
basically says it we often spend so much
of our lives trying to not listen to our
inner selves and to try and run away
from it or to try and shut it down and
whether we shut it down with alcohol
whether we shut it down by going to
graduate school that's not really for us
but or for our parents whether we shut
it down by doing something else that
we're expecting that we spend lots of
our life trying to not listen to who we
really are what we really want to do and
I think for whatever combination of
reasons I think for better or worse I
was willing as I became insane most of
us are interested in a variety of things
Manning very few of us are internally
one thing right like we could pretend
that's true but like that's not really
true right we all have lots of different
kinds of music some of you probably
listen to both Kanye and Sinatra right
and and you don't think that's where you
just think that's kind of who you are
and that's kind of what you like and so
I think I was willing to try that I
honestly think
part of my willingness to try new and
different things I often say I give
credit not only to my dad but to my mom
and and I worked a lot with students
over the years I think a lot of us
aren't again when at the paulo coelho
aren't always encouraged to kind of
pursue our dreams and really kind of
believe in ourselves and there's a
little bit of or a large bit of
insecurity that I think that often
prevents us from getting out of line
right and so out of safety we kind of
stay in line and we stay in the herd
whether or not that's really right for
us and I think my mom who had been a
teacher she would she was a mother late
in life so she got married late and then
had four kids between the age of 36 and
41 which in that era would be like
saying between 44 and 48 probably today
so but I think she's been a teacher for
a long time and and I think she
appreciated that people learn different
ways and and and she was a very
affirming person and so I never take
that for granted and particularly when I
work with with lots of young people I
realized a lot of people don't have that
in their life so I know that's not
exactly the answer you were expecting
but but I think that that my willingness
to to allow life to have some jagged
edges and to not treat that as weird but
actually maybe to say that that's maybe
a little more real I think came probably
from even though it necessarily come
from a wealthy background and even
though I didn't really come from a
family that had a lot of entrepreneurs a
lot of people have done TV or any of the
kinds of things that sometimes would
made those feel safer and easier to do I
think I think she just did a very good I
mean a lot of things but but among the
things is I think I was really fortunate
to to have a mom who just kind of saved
like go for it and um she often don't
say like what's the worst that can
happen she said I'm going to love you no
matter what she's like what's the worst
that could happen
and so again I I'm very aware that not
everyone has had the benefit of that and
and I'm not saying that's the only
reason why I ended up trying these
different
let's say that that was part of it so I
don't know if that is exactly the answer
you were expecting or thinking along
yeah you know it's ending you know some
of you guys may have heard the wonderful
commencement address given maybe a dozen
years ago by Steve Jobs here at Stanford
and you see this thing where he talks
about when you look at your life in
retrospect you know a bunch of things
may come together from a calligraphy
class to to other things in order to
kind of make sense then obviously that
kind of synthesis doesn't happen for
everyone but but where it does happen
that's that's a wonderful thing so I'll
tell you that was that's probably I but
a curiosity probably is the other piece
too but that I've always been that I've
always been curious and and like good
challenges and and like the sense that
I'm learning and and probably felt like
whether I was going to start up or
whether I was fortunate enough to be at
a place like McKenzie or or whether I
was hosting shows that I would I was
learning and and I am my mom used to
joke they bought back in the day they
had encyclopedias physical encyclopedias
and in World Book and not people would
come door-to-door and sell those and she
and my dad made a big investment to buy
them and they put them in my room and
she used to say I just read them for fun
and so I think I've always kind of had
this hunger for for learning more and
and get a lot of joy out of that and so
underlying each of these startups that
underlined some of the other work I've
done that's a that's probably been a
part of it
when you're describing your first couple
years reconnaissance list the first year
everything is fantastic if you're on top
the world and then I'm sure it isn't
and we also narratives on that
but you say with decided not to close
Lourdes and that something drove you
through this really dark period that in
came surely with something that's great
what was it you ever feel but okay I can
interchange horses totally do something
different or full women from you through
that country uh you know I probably take
several things one just what we were
doing so so I am fortunate that that I
actually genuinely loved what we were
doing and I and that's probably part of
it and I always I still always feel
lucky because I know that a lot of
people work hard but never actually get
to help start something and so it's
weird as that sound so even when the
things aren't going well I realize it
it's not every day someone gets to start
something probably responsibility
knowing that a lot of people who wired
real money to us a lot of people move
from different parts of the country or
world to come join us too so I realizes
that can sound a little at worst
paternalistic but I do feel like I have
a responsibility to people who are
betting on us and so I feel like I owe
something uh to them but you know kind
of I'm naturally competitive but I'll
tell you what you know recommend getting
a lot of motivation from even more
reasonably sports
I've always loved sports and and the
number of times and I'm not an anyone
here in New England Patriots fan I'm not
a New England Patriots fan but those
guys inspire me for those of you who
aren't pro football fans this team over
the last 15 years is won the Super Bowl
five times the only people who are in
common not the only but the main
characters who are in common or the
owner the coach and the star quarterback
now you could argue to start quarterback
you the greatest of all time but last
year they lose their second best player
Rob Gronkowski right before the playoffs
and do they give up do they wave the
white flag do they say no mas no they
get a guy who basically didn't play
college football played lacrosse in
college and put him out there and he's
catching a half dozen passes in the
Superbowl and they're on their way to
coming back and
I would say believe it or not all of
these interesting comebacks in the last
year whether it was the Cleveland
Cavaliers hate to say that in the Bay
Area but down 3-1 uh whether it's the
Cubbies whether it's uh in college
basketball when I went to college myself
and saw Villanova a year plus ago
Clemson and so that also is played a
role too
also the last thing I will say is that
and when people used to say this to me
before I didn't fully believe it but
definitely being older has helped there
are things that when I was in my 20s
first start up they would grind my
stomach all night there'd be issues I'd
worry about and I wouldn't get sleep for
multiple days and I would just struggle
with them and they would just they would
just cause me the blues and I think that
today with a little more experience and
being able to maybe see things in a
broader context they don't wear me down
in the same way and so it probably is a
little bit like a boxer who you know
that same blow when that boxer was 18 or
19 might really ring their Bell and now
for better or worse and so um um but but
also you know a number of times we've
been really fortunate in having
unexpected people on our team step up
one of the best people we've hired was a
guy know we've we've hired a lot of
journalists who came from classic
backgrounds New York Times The Economist
CNN we've hired some that come from
alternative background vice GQ some of
the best people we've hired or people I
call cross-trainers one guy had never
been a journalist before he was a board
lawyer in a small town in North Carolina
and he has ended up no one else would
have taken a chance on him he's the guy
named Sean Braswell he's ended up
writing some of our best pieces and in
fact two of our first three television
shows have been based on things that
he's written
another guy we just hired was an
accountant for a restaurant chain in New
Jersey and um he loved what we were
doing he pursued us for probably three
four or five months he ended up writing
about a dozen freelance pieces and when
we finally met him we were like are you
willing to take a pay cut and you will
in the
were you willing to lean in and kind of
learn this craft and make it work and he
was and he ended up being terrific for
us so the other thing I think that
probably also helped me get through was
just seeing how hard other people were
pushing and feeling like I mean
hopefully I would have done my part no
matter what but but but definitely I
couldn't let them do it and I'm not I'm
not doing my part so ok of the things
you've done as the location you know
Allah says this house James II does that
matter for the tapes of your time to be
all right you can do it any way in and
all that lets your assessment you know I
think that's a great question so we're
based here in Mountain View we're based
locally and a lot of people have seen
that as a as a bad idea a lot of folks
have said as a media company you'd want
to be with the New York Times in order
by sand box and BuzzFeed and NPR and
others are so likely New York or or DC
or worse you might want to be in San
Francisco or Oakland and we originally
were here honestly because my mom lived
here and I needed to be to be close but
how no I love mountain view you know
they always joked that I'm I should be
present the Chamber of Commerce because
I'm such a big fan and I actually I
always wanted it you know even after
things changed and if I wanted to I
could have I could have left the area I
kind of wanted our team to be here
because I felt like if we were in New
York they would always compare
themselves with Vice and box and budget
New York Times I actually wanted their
competitive set to include Apple and
Tesla and snap and uber and others and
so I wanted them to really think big and
to be open and I wanted people who they
were bumping into at dinner and at
parties and other places to include that
set and not just the other set so I
often admire what happened at ESPN which
started in a little middle of nowhere no
disrespect to Connecticut but Bristol
Connecticut which
a bustling metropolis but that's where
they built for what was has been for a
time the most successful TV network and
I don't necessarily think that's an
accident and so yes I think a lot of
times we would have an easier time
recruiting we'd have fewer issues with
commuting and those sorts of things but
I like being in Silicon Valley I like
being somewhere different and I think in
many ways it keeps us different and it
makes us bolder and it makes us consider
crazy ideas that turn into television
shows or festivals or other sorts of
things that I think we otherwise
wouldn't have done because that's not
what the most natural competitive set
was doing I think we've been less
followers and more leaders because we're
gonna call Mountain View the wilderness
but but but we're we're not on we're not
on the same path so he gets in ok
how does Ozzie make money and has that
compared to traditional media so a lot
of the folks you know whether it's the
Huffington Post or a bleacher report or
Mashable or Business Insider or box or
or others of the new digital media
players have made money with advertising
and they call it different things at
time they call it branded content or
sponsorship or they've got all sorts of
kind of clever names where the bottom
line is they're trying to get P&G and
crafts and other people that spend
advertising dollars with them and I
think that's a fine business and
obviously Google and Facebook and proven
then add Alex you can build a nice
business based on that we have done that
and worked with a lot of good
advertisers be they Netflix or Spotify
or Hulu or others who who advertise on
Ozzy but two other ways one as I
mentioned to you before we started
getting calls from Hollywood about a
year after we launched and people were
saying we like the series have you ever
thought about them as a TV show or movie
first time we heard that we got super
excited and I went to go see some of the
guys I knew advice and they were like
calm down um I know you're excited but
they whispered the same sweet nothings
to us we didn't get our first big TV
show for 17 years so it's probably not
going to happen but we still decide to
go have the conversations with people
and got really lucky and sold our
very first show and subsequently have
sold two other shows and so television
revenue is kind of a second way and then
a third way is we do these pretty
detailed reader surveys at the end of
every year and within our first year we
started to hearing from leaders and
viewers who said they didn't use this
language they said I like I'd love Ozzy
online but I almost wish I could meet
Ozzy in the real world and since it
firstly started we started to think
about doing small events in the way that
fortune and the economists and the
Atlantic and others had done recode
TechCrunch and so we start talking about
n smallness but a really smart woman who
worked for the city of New York was like
guys you're not being ambitious enough
she said South by Southwest used to be
this incredible thing it's become a
little overrun little sprawl II why
don't you aim higher build something of
greater scale that not right away but
over time maybe thought of one day is
the new South by Southwest and so we
made a five-year commitment to the city
of New York to build something called
oddly fast which is a wonderful festival
if any of you are in New York this
summer in July 22nd and 23rd it was
described last summer is I think The
Times called it Ted meets Coachella and
so it's a really nice mix but musicians
and actors and athletes and
entrepreneurs and and others and and so
that's become quite a revenue source for
us so there are three revenue sources
for Ozzie so far which we're excited
about which the only other player who's
among the new players who were doing
that advise it has multiple revenue
sources most of the other ones from
BuzzFeed to HuffPo to box and mic and
skim and those mainly or advertising and
so we're hopeful that even though it was
harder to really get each of these
things going early on that will hold in
the next four or five years it will be
proud of the fact that we build good
roots from the very beginning so thank
you guys so much what a treat it was
good to be with you I hope it was
helpful
thank you
you